rituel de sports collectifs en tenues
d'équitation il ne peut s'agir que de
horse ball une discipline inventée en
france dans les années soixante dix
sorte de mélange acrobatique et
spectaculaire entre le basket et le
rugby
sur le terrain des chevaux petits
rapides et endurants parfaitement à
l'ecoute de leurs cavaliers qui se passe
en fait au niveau des jambes les mains
l'assiette 7 enfin tout ce qui se passe
sous vos fesses en fait c'est vraiment
et en effet c'est invisible parce que ce
sont des actions quand on devient
cavaliers ces actions sont tellement
naturel entre guillemets qu'elles
deviennent invisibles échauffements
d'avant match pour les joueurs du blanc
avant de s'occuper de leurs montures ou
plutôt de leurs partenaires s'acheva le
très très dynamique sur le terrain est
très maniable et c'est un cheval qui des
gros points de force sur la défense ils
défendent très bien le côté droit c'est
là où il ya le plus d attaques et will
assez polyvalent dans le jeu sur tous
les postes
l'équipe berrichonne affronte celle
d'angers supérieur sur le papier les
joueurs du blanc résiste sur la première
mi temps de dix minutes 3 buts partout
mais les choses vont se gâter en
deuxième période et nos berrichon bon
finalement s'incliner cette buse à 5 ans
prend pas mal de buts aussi en contre
attaque
et donc voilà on n'a pas su rebondir et
se retrouver dans nos attaques on n'a
pas su mettre le jeu qu'on avait mis en
place en première mi temps
une petite déception pour cette équipe
du blanc qui a été l'une des meilleures
mondiales et qui peine aujourd'hui à
retrouver le très haut niveau